stronger in a smaller constituency but a
majority over 92 percent are turnout
over 58 again busting through the
government's thresholds we regret to say
on support staff in England although 15
405 voted yester strike and only 2 900
voted no a very big majority of 84 but
because of the government's unfair
undemocratic thresholds the the majority
the turnout in that was 46 and that's
not enough for us to call Legal strike
action however support staff in Wales
again beat the thresholds with the
Turner of 51.3 a majority of 88.26 these
ballot results are amazing
the England teacher ballot results alone
is the biggest ballot result of any
Union in recent times
certainly since this quadratic threshold
was introduced in 2017 2016. we have
come with our England and Wales ballot
together spanning 23 400 schools our
teacher members England and Wales our
support staff members in Wales have
voted in enough numbers to beat both of
the government's thresholds for
industrial action that have been imposed
on teachers another essential public
service over of all teacher members of
the Union voted by post when there was
significant disruption to The Postal
Service the government needs to listen
these are Big votes for strike action
[Music]
really important it shows the government
that the Neu members will not stand by
and see the Education Service they work
so hard for and they care for so much be
sacrificed because teachers and support
staff are being driven from the
profession they love because of a toxic
mix of low pay and excessive workload
neither should the support of the South
figures in England give the government
any cheer the hard facts cannot be
ignored children are losing out because
there aren't enough teachers and support
staff
parents and grandparents hear their
children and grandchildren talking about
new teachers in the middle of the school
year of their favorite teachers leaving
of teachers not being available in the
subject that they are learning
parents of children with special
educational needs know that support
staff
that the support staff their children
rely on to access learning are leaving
schools to work in supermarkets because
they can be paid more there
public servants are suffering the
longest period of pay suppression since
the Napoleonic Wars
a teacher who started work in 2010 and
made normal progress up the pay scale
has lost over 64 000 pounds in cash
terms support staff have lost 27 percent
of their pay in real terms since 2010
and that's why teacher recruitment is in
crisis with a 23 percent fall in
applications this year that's why
teacher retention is in crisis with 40
percent of teachers leaving within 10
years of qualification with one in eight
leaving within two years of
qualification that's why secondary class
sizes are now the highest that they have
ever been it's why primary plus sizes
are the highest they've been since 2000
and these are not my words these are the
words of Amanda Spielman who I don't
normally quote with approval
among the Spielman the Chief Inspector
of ofsted is written in her latest
ofsted annual report but remember 20 to
2. that there's a Workforce crisis in
our schools
the school leaders report that
recruiting and retaining teachers and
support staff is their biggest challenge
in work
and that children and young people are
bearing the brunt of that crisis without
access to the teachers and support they
need in order to get the education they
are entitled to
okay
so we've got some shout outs and thanks
to everybody for popping some messages
on there and one from Jenny Cooper who
says a massive well done to all of our
reps and I looked absolutely second that
as well and message from Julie saying
great news thanks to everybody
um also brilliant news from Dion and Tim
says excellent news all School workers
worked and deserve a decent properly
funded pay raise
Michaela is saying excellent result
absolutely agree very good result but
very hard work from everybody who's been
involved in it and Dale as a trainee
teacher I'm with everyone who was going
on strike the Tories are destroying
everything and then just one final shout
out as well which I think I absolutely
fully agree with fantastic results and
proud to be part of Neu
you know mayor has just given you a
quote from Amanda Spielman but just in
the last week we have seen studies from
The Institute of fiscal studies Barry
was at an event today with the National
Fund for
Education research all confirming the
arguments that we're making about why
there is a shortage of teachers all of
them saying there is going to have to be
a correction on teacher pay but we know
it's the reality the daily stress of
working in an underfunding school with
exhausted staff receiving poor pay which
has led Neu members to vote Yes for
strike action we know that you haven't
taken this decision lightly you want to
be in your classrooms teaching and
supporting children and young people the
decision to strike for all of us is the
last resort
so we do intend to make this work
our Aim so uh we were promised that we'd
hear the results of those ballots uh
dead on the dots or five o'clock and uh
so it came to Pass the Joint General
secretaries of the National Education
Union there Kevin Courtney and Mary
boosted joined by the national president
uh Louise Atkinson teachers in England
and Wales are set to go on strike in
February and March after members of the
Union that voted in favor of action in
their ongoing dispute over pay they say
that the ballot is a result of failure
by the Secretary of State in England and
the employees in Wales to ensure enough
money is available to pay a fully funded
increase in pay for teachers which at
least matches inflation and which begins
to restore lost pay well our chief
political correspondent John Craig is in
Westminster for us so we heard from Mary
boosted a little bit earlier today on
Sky News John saying that she believed
that they would meet the threshold and
so they have teachers are going to go on
strike
they have in all but one of the ballots
that was support staff uh the result of
the news we've just heard is that there
are going to be uh potentially seven
strikes uh in February and March some of
them National some of them Regional the
first uh is on Wednesday the 1st of sept
of February Wednesday the 1st of
February now that is the day that the
TUC is holding its National protect the
right to strike day a real day of action
when we've already know that the civil
servants in the PCS Trade union 100
thousands of them are already striking
that day so teachers on the 1st of
February all eligible members in England
and Wales then on the 14th of February
all and eligible members in Wales on the
28th of February all eligible members in
the these English regions Northern North
West Yorkshire and the Humber Wednesday
the 1st of March all eligible members in
the East Midlands West Midlands and
Eastern Thursday the 2nd of March all
eligible members in London Southeast and
Southwest Wednesday the 15th of March
all eligible members in England and
Wales and Thursday the 16th of March all
eligible members in England and Wales so
by my Reckoning that's three strikes in
the whole of England and Wales the other
four are Regional strikes so
um that of course has set the the
teachers on collision course with the
government it was education questions in
the House of Commons a little earlier
this afternoon now Jillian Keegan said
she she said during uh the topical
questions she was going to meet the
teaching unions later this week so one
would assume that those strikes will go
ahead unless there is a breakthrough in
talks between the teaching unions and
Jillian Keegan later this week just to
that that's that that those that trade
Union is the National Education Union
um as far as I'm aware we haven't yet
heard from the National Association of
head teachers they are also due to make
an announcement of course they're in
fact John sorry sorry to interrupt just
literally as you're speaking John we
have just heard from them and
interestingly uh they haven't reached
the legal requirement for turnout in
England uh votes counted for 42 percent
of the Union's membership which is short
of the 50
needed this is for the naht which
represents uh leaders in schools in
England Wales and Northern Ireland so
that's interesting John isn't it because
like the nas uwt which also didn't reach
the required threshold it means that
that ballot doesn't count
well it means that'll be an immense
relief to the government uh because it
probably means that contingency plans uh
for the uh strikes by the Neu can go
ahead I suppose it's not entirely
surprising I mean you would expect I
suppose head teachers to be less likely
to vote for strike action for a start
they're better paid and obviously
they're more senior and that they might
feel as head teachers that perhaps they
shouldn't be going on strike and
plunging as schools into crisis and
depriving children of their lessons so I
guess the N A an EU will they'll be
disappointed but the government will be
mightily relieved that head teachers are
not going to go on strike it's just the
classroom teachers members of the Neu
the National Education Union so it means
contingency plans can go ahead and as I
said in the Commons this afternoon
Jillian Keegan the education secretary
did say she's going to meet the teaching
unions later this week
so no doubt she will be hoping for some
sort of breakthrough there but the
unions will say well look there's no
more money on the table where these
strikes are going ahead seven of them by
my record it's three Nash three National
England and Wales and uh and four in
various regions of England so at seven
strikes a lot of strikes
um and of course we are expecting uh in
a short time to hear from the Royal
College of Nursing what they're planning
to do in terms of strikes and we learned
today that the GMB Union representing
ambulance Crews have raised the prospect
of up to six strikes by ambulance crews
in the next few months we're likely to
hear those dates uh on Wednesday so a
lot happening a lot of strikes coming up
okay John uh in Westminster for us uh
with that breaking news many thanks
teachers in England are well set to go
on strike in February and March after
members of the Neu voted in favor of
action in their dispute overpay and as
you can see there we will have a special
program for you at 7 pm tonight a panel
of experts answering your questions on
those teachers strikes uh you can watch
that at seven o'clock right here on Sky
News
now the Metropolitan Police have
apologized following the conviction of a
serving officer who admitted dozens of
offenses against women including 24
counts of rape PC David Carrick was
allowed to continue serving despite
complaints against him going back to the
year 2000. it wasn't until he was
arrested on suspicion of rape in October
2021 that he was suspended the police
have acknowledged that his abusive
Behavior should have been picked up on
behalf of